there's tension among large groups of
people there's tension among very
different adherence of two very
different ideologies and belief systems
absolutely let's start with this country
in this country there is no vast and
easily defined clash of civilizations
there is no Islamic movement that wants
to take over the country and impose
Sharia the the complex Islamic set of
legal ideas and rules and regulations on
to American society now are there Muslim
preachers who say that God would prefer
that we live by Islamic rule yeah you
can go to mosques and find people saying
the same way you can find some Christian
preachers who would say that the
heathens are running this country and in
when God's kingdom come they'll all be
swept aside and incinerated and the good
people will be taken to heaven and sit
at Jesus's right hand I mean you know
every a lot of different groups have
kind of apocalyptic ideas they have the
notion that their ideas and their belief
systems superior to others I mean
traditionally that's kind of what
religion is all about like we got a
bunch of ideas they're better than your
ideas and God's listening to us not so
much to you so that you know that's why
we should be in charge now we're a lot
more advanced from that position in this
country I'm and Muslims are I think
fully able to exist in a pluralistic
society even if they disagree with their
neighbors even if they disapprove of
people eating pork or drinking alcohol
with dinner or even if they hold vaguely
or poor very pronounced anti-semitic
views just to choose one thing the way
many of my relatives I'm Jewish just as
an aside have you know extremely bigoted
views about Arabs and Muslims that's no
big secret among Jews so is there a
clash of civilizations well I mean
you've got preachers all over the world
declaring that there is a clash of
civilizations you have ideologues who
want to emphasize that you have
countries
at war you have mullahs in Iran stamping
on people who don't want to live
according to you so they've got a lot of
clashing all over the place and I
suppose you could use as your organizing
prism for all that you're organizing
filter that there are clashes of civil
you sure they're my I guess my reaction
is when weren't there clashes of
civilization and of what great use is
that analytical construct and in this
country I would say it's a very very
little use you absolutely focus on the
tensions absolutely look at where
there's friction look at where there are
discrepancies between aspirations and
ideals and the reality of how people get
along that's my book in is in part about
but declaring that there's a clash of
civilizations and kind of the guys on
the other side of the Kalasha have to
get with our program or we're all going
a war or in the title of a recent you
know extremely unhelpful book about you
know the coming world war for I mean I
just don't see how that whole thing
really helps